[Music]
they say
one man's trash is another man's
treasure and lately that even applies to
the food we eat
yes it does up cycle foods are made from
ingredients that
would usually be thrown out now they're
further processed into marketable
products
reducing food waste with a positive
impact on the environment
and while the term may be new you may
have already eaten some upcycled snacks
and other items
oh wow nancy chen has the story
we're like the weird people asking about
like the waste instead
of the beer you know like when you went
on brewery tours yeah yeah yeah we're
the only ones asking like what is your
waste
what do you do with it when berta
jimenez moved to the united states from
ecuador for graduate school
she never expected to be on the cutting
edge of baking
before you started all this you weren't
really a beer drinker
or a baker that's correct my background
was mechanical engineering so
nothing related with baking but when she
showed up at kagan lantern brewing
company in brooklyn new york
with a bucket in hand head brewer jeff
lyons
had just what she was looking to tap
into
what is this so this is malted barley
this is the
aftermath you must produce a lot of this
absolutely we probably have about a
dozen of these on average per week
that spank grain has long been discarded
but with the goal of sustainability
jimenez co-founded rice a company
collecting nutritious scraps
otherwise thrown away during food
production to make flour
that's 12 times the fiber two times the
proteins and one third of the carbs
it's like really really delicious and
it's also sustainable
they transformed that food waste into
ingredients for new products
and a process called upcycling rise's
first target
malted barley so best case scenario this
would go to animal feed
worst case scenario this goes to a
landfill yes instead
she made it something to eat jimenez and
her team preparing what they call
super flower crafted for bloggers and
pilsners
it returned with surprising feedback
from a chef
we said like we are so sorry that it has
some flavor
and he was like actually like that part
that i really like
since launching in 2017 rise has quickly
expanded
partnering with bakeries and restaurants
they've also started consulting major
companies on how to reuse their waste
including beer giant anheuser-busch
while jimenez says
rice flour is the first of its kind
she's far from alone
upcycling was featured as a top trend of
2021
by both food network magazine and whole
foods
turner wyatt created the upcycled food
association in 2019.
what exactly is upcycled food it's a way
of taking otherwise wasted food
and creating something new and
nutritious
out of it to prevent food waste about
1.3 billion tons of food are wasted
every year globally the association
represents more than 140 businesses
across 20 countries some are big
companies like dole
while others are startups with product
lines devoted solely to upcycled food
like snacks made of salmon skins or
makeup powder crafted from rice starch
there's already more than 400 up cycled
products on the market
but consumers don't know which ones they
are because there's no
label there's no way to identify
which are the upcycled products that's
until next week when the association
will unveil a new label on earth day
soon to be seen on shelves nationwide it
certifies a net positive impact on the
environment
taking into account manufacturing and
transportation
and while the term upcycling is new the
practice is as traditional as simmering
scraps or broth
as it is innovative is upcycling the
solution to food waste
i would say it's one of the solutions
ned spang is an associate professor of
food science and technology
at uc davis and works with the upcycled
food association
what could the impact of upcycling be on
the food supply chain
i think it's less likely to disrupt it
and more likely to kind of
improve it it helps us to do more with
with less what we're already producing
could this really change the way we
think about how we eat
i think that really is the first step
not just for upcycling but thinking
about food
food loss and waste in general is that
we think about our role as a consumer
that sustainability can reap benefits
thousands of miles away like at a cacao
farm in costa rica
here the cacao fruit is used almost in
its entirety to create a new brain of
chocolate called
candid canted noons is still chocolate
yeah it's still chocolate chris
kajander's candid ceo
he engineered a way to use part of the
fruit usually thrown out
we essentially extract the pulp and
remove it set it aside
and then go about making chocolate
the way chocolate is made and then we
reincorporate the pulp
as the primary sweetener to actually see
it in my hand right here is you realize
how much of it does get thrown out
if all you're using are the seeds
launched last year noons are already in
400 stores nationwide
chocolate returning to its origins
am i eating the seeds was i supposed to
spit the seed out
well it tastes good the upcycling
movement aims to readjust our concept of
food
even how we describe it when anything
and everything
can be ingredients all of these things
it's been declared a waste
because the way we treat it but if we
just change
the supply of how we take it how we
transport it how we store it
it shouldn't be a waste it should be an
ingredient it should be food it should
be
whatever you want to make it with them
it shouldn't go to the landfill
for cbs this morning saturday nancy chen
new york
it's really interesting maybe this is my
thought process i love the idea of it
but sometimes i don't know if i want to
know that it's upside down
so i like that they've got a label i
like knowing it's helping our
environment
but well i like the 12 times the fiber
what is it
so the yeah the upcycled flour has 12
times the fiber two times the protein
and a third of the carbs as normal
that's a good thing again
it's always it's not a bad thing and you
know those those nibs those little seeds
they are delicious
those things oh my god so good